[Music]
this is the face of the yes campaign
thousands rallied in parks and City
centers across the country on Sunday
showing support for greater recognition
of Australia's First Nations people it's
one of those moments I think where
um I personally want to be on the right
side of history and I think the history
of Australian politics around Aboriginal
culture is quite dismal we have the
great privileges Australians to have
such an ancient Community continuous
culture in our in our nation and it's
important that they're recognized
Parliament past legislation clearing the
way for a referendum later this year
Australians will vote on whether the
Constitution should be amended to
recognize indigenous Australians for the
first time and to establish an advisory
body representing Aboriginal and Torres
Strait Islanders guiding Federal
Parliament the yes campaign declared
Sunday a national day of action
today is all about
Australian people going out to the
people they know in their workplace
homes sporting areas and saying this is
nothing to be scared of this is a just
thing this is a thing that Nation mature
you know opinion polls show support for
the yes campaign has fallen below 50
percent the federal Coalition party has
already declared it will vote against
the Constitutional change some within
the Aboriginal Community have also
questioned whether the proposed law
known as The Voice will be enough to
address the serious problems facing
indigenous communities we are going
backwards we are going backwards in
indigenous Health we are going backwards
and Indigenous life expectancy
we're going backwards in the the right
of Aboriginal people black people in
this country being locked up
um things up on that slippery slide
backlits we've got to try something else
Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander
people represent around three percent of
nearly 26 million Australians the
federal government says the referendum
will be a once in a generation chance to
give indigenous communities a greater
voice at a national level
for the yes campaign to be successful
the Bal Nina majority in four of the Six
States they'll also need a national
majority the latest poll suggests
they're ahead in just two states the
referendum is expected to be held in
October Sarah Clarke Al Jazeera Sydney